- - Martine Biron, Christian
DuDufour, Stéphanie, bonsoir.
OnOn va revenir sur le budget
d'd'abord, beaucoup d'ébullition
auaujourd'hui à Québec, Martine,
llà-dessus. Je vais vous faire
atattendre l'opposition qui en a
cocontre 500 $ qui est donné à
trtrop de monde, pas uniquement
auaux gens qui en avaient vraimt
bebesoin.
EtEt M. Legault qui répond.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Il y a toute une génération,
auaujourd'hui, qui ne sait pas i
elelle va être capable, un jour,
dede s'acheter une maison.
IlIl y avait des propositions
coconcrètes, on en avait fait :
bobonifiées le RAP, doubler
leles crédits d'impôt à l'achat
d'd'une première maison, s'assur
ququ'on encadrait les flips.
RiRien de tout ça ne se trouve
dadans le budget. Pourquoi
lele premier ministre a laissé
totomber cette génération?
MAMANON MASSÉ, députée, QS
SaSainte-Marie - Saint-Jacques
- - Il sait pas c'est quoi
vivivre avec un salaire normal.
SoSon chèque de 500 piastres,
c'c'est 1,37 piastre par jour.
CÇa paye pas les hausses de loyr
ababusives qu'il y a eues, en ps
avavec l'extra de l'augmentation
d'd'Hydro-Québec le mois procha.
C'C'est même pas assez pour
s's'acheter un café chez
TiTim Hortons.
MAMARTIN OUELLET, porte-parole
dudu PQ en matière de finances
- - En quoi de donner 1000 $
àà deux personnes qui vivent
acaccotées et qui gagnent
10100 000 $ est une mesure
éqéquitable pour les Québécois?
- - Je pense que, trop souvent,
onon oublie la classe moyenne.
PuPuis, c'est pas vrai que
leles gens qui gagnent plus de
4040 ou 50 000 $ par année ont s
étété affectés par l'inflation.
C'C'est à chaque Québécois
dede décider ce qu'ils font
avavec cet argent-là plutôt que
dede les tenir par la main.
- - Alors Martine, ses revenus,n
n'n'en parlait hier, c'est
OnOn aurait voulu voir d'autres
memesures pour l'aide au logeme.
SuSur la 500, c'était prévisibl?
- - Honnêtement, les partis de
l'l'opposition étaient tous sure
mmême pied, autant pour les
memesures qu'ils auraient voulu
vovoir plus large ou pour la
pépénurie de main-d'oeuvre. Poua
50500 $ aussi, ils estimaient qe
c'c'était trop, que c'était
bebeaucoup pour des gens qui
ététaient en moyen. Ceci dit, il
n'n'y a pas tant de revenu
fafamilial de 200 000, cette
poportion là est assez grave,
c'c'est à la baisse. M. Legault
fafait ça pour plusieurs raison.
D'D'abord, c'est sur quel combat
l'l'inflation, mais en même tems
ilil envoie un petit cadeau assz
élélectoral a de la classe
momoyenne, 35 quarante-cinquièm,
fafamilial, qui est vraiment
exexaspéré par les mesures, et i
cocommença à regarder du côté ds
coconservateurs. C'est une mesue
asassez adroite.Et c'est quand
mmême assez habile ça va faire n
efeffet à court terme. Monsieur
LeLegault va pouvoir continuer à
memettre de l'avant de nouvelles
memesures.
- - Stéphanie, vous avez écrit -
dedessus, vous avais même cité
DuDuPlessis...
- - c'est sûr que c'était un cln
d'd'oeil avec un sourire. C'est
vrvrai qu'à l'époque de Dupless,
onon achetait des élections avec
bebeaucoup de route. Je ne dis s
ququ'on essaie d'acheter les
élélecteurs, mais c'est certain
quque c'est une mesure
élélectoraliste et qu'on est à x
momois des élections. Monsieur
LeLegault n'est pas différent ds
auautres partis politiques, il
n'n'est pas ça traversa.
OnOn a vu Justin Trudeau faire a
mmême chose avant les dernières
élélections. L'envoi du chèque r
hahasard comme ça avant les
élélections, c'est une stratégie
bebeaucoup répandue qui est
didifficile à résister. Il faut
cocomprendre qu'on ne combat pas
d'd'inflation en ajoutant de
l'l'argent dans le système. Au
cocontraire, ça va avoir des
efeffets néfastes. C'est comme i
onon arrose un incendie avec de
l'l'essence, ça va exacerber
l'l'inflation. Contrer
l'l'inflation, j'étais d'accord,
j'j'ai trouvé que les mesures qi
ététaient adoptées dans le mini
bubudget l'automne dernier était
lologique. Il faut comprendre qe
ceces gens-là consacrent le deux
titiers de leur budget à des
dédépenses essentielles, alors e
leles gens plus fortunés, c'est
seseulement le quart. Alors
popourquoi donner à une famillùu
leles deux parents gagnent juste
unun peu moins de 100 000, les
dedeux enfants sont majeurs, ces
gegens-là vont avoir chacun 500,
202000 $ dans une famille, ça ft
bebeaucoup d'argent, alors qu'ue
mmère monoparentale qui a deux
enenfants mineurs, elle va avoir
50500 $, même si elle gagne
seseulement 25 000 ou 30 000.
- - Vous en aviez donné plus à
ceceux qui en ont beaucoup beso?
- - Je pense que c'était logique
dede cibler mieux.
- - Christian, sur cette opératn
50500 $?
- - Je suis assez d'accord avec
StStéphanie. Pour la classe
momoyenne, un coup qui fait 200
00000 $... c'est quand qu'on est
dadans l'électoraliste. Si vouse
pepermettez, pour ne pas répéter
cece qui a été dit, faire un
cocommentaire qui est plus
ididentitaire et sociétal, on ns
didit qu'on est riche les
ququébécois depuis hier, c'est
memerveilleux, on donne de
l'l'argent du monde qui en ont s
bebesoin, on n'est pas habitué à
çaça sur le point identitaire.Ça
m'm'inquiète un peu que ce soite
seseul message parce que je troe
ququ'au Québec, le réflexe
spspontané quand il y a des
prproblèmes, on dit qu'il va y
avavoir plus d'argent, le
fifinancement plus de ressource.
C'C'est un message qui est
ininsidieux parce que plus qu'on
nanage dans l'argent et qu'on et
ririche... on nous dit qu'on va
réréformer le système de santé..
c'c'est merveilleux de faire des
ququ'on est riche, il y a aucun
inincitatif à changer.
- - Je posais la question minise
hihier, la santé recevra 9
mimilliards de plus pour les
prprochaines années, c'est une
auaugmentation de 6,3 % du budgt
dede la santé, alors la
ReRefondation est d'autant plus
imimportant, vous dîtes quque il
fafaut que ça marche mieux?
- - Je veux faire un commentaire
ququi va m'attirer les
cocommentaires haineux. J'ai eu
unune petite pensée pour le
prpremier ministre Couillard qui
onont tranché la nouvelle ère ds
seservices de finances publique.
JeJe pense AU parce que c'est ps
trtrès à la mode de se souvenir
dedes libéraux.
- - Sur Québec, Martine, ça, c't
inintéressant, on va avoir le
prpropos d'Éric Caire qui a
atattaqué le maire de Québec de
fafaçon directe à disant que le
trtramway ne fonctionne pas, la
cicirculation va augmenter...
onon va l'écouter.
EÉRIC CAIRE, député, CAQ
LaLa Peltrie
- - Le maire dit qu'il veut pas
fafaire une guerre à l'automobi?
QuQu'il le prouve et qu'il
ararrête de polluer l'existence
dedes conducteurs avec
dedes projets comme ça.
BRBRUNO MARCHAND, maire de Québc
- - Ça suppose une vision d'aver
ququi fait qu'on n'est pas là
popour nous, on est pas là pour
unune élection, on n'est pas là
popour gagner un comté,
unune circonscription parce qu'n
a a peur de X, Y ou Z, mais
paparce qu'on fait notre travail
enen pensant aux gens pour
ququi on le fait.
- - Monsieur Caire, il a dit qul
esest allé trop loin.
IlIl est une personne de bonne
fofoi, etc. Martine, il y a deux
vivisions qui s'affrontent à
QuQuébec, on voit que la CAQ est
d'd'un côté il ne veut pas être
peperçu comme étant de l'autre.
- - Il y a un an je viens
cocontexte. L'enjeu est que le
mamaire de Québec veut avoir son
trtramway pour la ville de Québc
enen disant que c'est pas pour s
babanlieues, c'est pour les gens
dudu Québec. La vision du
gogouvernement est plus globale,
onon appelle ça le réseau expres
dede Québec. Il va y avoir le
trtramway à Québec et le troisie
lilien, l'un ne va pas sans
l'l'autre. On trouve à Québec le
mamaire de Québec ne se mouille
papas sur le troisième lien, als
ququ'il y a eu quand même
plplusieurs réunions, on travaie
àà un nouveau projet du troisièe
gagagner un peu plus économiquet
onon voudrait qu'il en parle.
AuAujourd'hui, d'ailleurs, dans
soson point de presse, il n'a ps
paparlé du troisième lien. Alors
çaça, c'est l'enjeu. Le contexte
esest que Monsieur Marchand a éé
élélu il y a six mois et son
ététoile brille. Ça va bien pour
lului, il est enflammé, il tient
soson bout. Alors que l'autre
popoliticien sans en élections
dadans six mois... c'est
didifficile. Il voit Monsieur
DuDuhaime avancer. Le caucus de
QuQuébec est nerveux, ça expliqe
unun peu la sortie de Eric Caire
trtrès enflammé. Mais il y en a
d'd'autres en caucus qui sont
imimportants pour la situation.
- - Voulez-vous commenter,
ChChristian?
- - Je viens d'apprendre cette
chchose la. J'ai été 24 ans
QuQuébec. Quelle culture politie
spspécifique! C'est ça qui me
frfrappe : le ton et l'émotion.
EÉric Duhaime, c'est là qu'il a
dudu succès. Québec, c'est
vrvraiment spécifique. Le ton et
fafascinant, en fait.
- - Ministère Québec, comme on
didisait. Hier, c'est alliance C
NPNPD a fait réagir aujourd'hui.
LeLegault qui a dit : faites
atattention.
- - Il va y avoir un affronteme,
popour chahuter le Québec, avec
totoutes les provinces;
enentre autres avec l'Ontario.
CeCe n'est pas vrai que Doug Fo,
enen Ontario, va accepter que
çaça soit Justin Trudeau qui die
cocomment on administre le budgt
dede la santé. Il y a un front
cocommun très fort des provinces
popour dire : La santé, c'est
unun champ de compétence
dedes provinces. Ce sont les
prprovinces qui sont les mieux
plplacés pour choisir. Mais là,
onon a deux partis très
cecentralisateurs, le parti
lilibéral du Canada et le NPD, i
veveulent imposer ça à l'ensembe
dedes provinces. Je pense
ququ'ils vont frapper un noeud.
MEMÉLANIE JOLY, ministre
dedes Affaires étrangères
- - Moi, je pense que quand
QuQuébec et Ottawa s'entendent,
c'c'est les Québécois qui gagne.
NoNous, de notre côté,
onon va toujours s'entendre.
PAPABLO RODRIGUEZ, lieutenant
popolitique pour le Québec, PLC
- - Bien, nous, ce que l'on
veveut, c'est collaborer avec
leles provinces là-dessus. Puis,
c'c'est quelque chose d'importa.
J'J'étais chez le dentiste
lala semaine dernière. Je sais s
sisi vous y allez régulièrement,
guguys, là, mais ça coûte cher.
CÇa coûte cher puis il y a des
fafamilles qui ont pas le moyens
pupuis soit qu'ils s'endettent
ouou, des fois, ils y vont pas.
StStéphanie, je commence avec
vovous, est-ce qu'ils vont frapr
unun noeud comme dit M. Legault?
- - Deux partis fédéraux qui sot
plplutôt centralisateurs et M.
LeLegault qui ne veut pas avoir
d'd'ingérence, que personne ne
vivienne piler dans ses plates-
babandes. Peut-être que pour lui
c'c'est une bonne chose parce qe
c'c'est toujours bien d'avoir un
enennemi avec qui se battre pare
ququ'il va pouvoir défendre les
inintérêts des Québécois. À la
veveille des élections, c'est
pepeut-être pas une si mauvaise
chchose que ça. Par contre, on
sasait vraiment que le fédéral
enenvoie des transparents santé,
trtransferts. Monsieur Lugo n'a
papas donné suite. C'est pas
dedemain qu'on a besoin de cet
arargent la.
UnUn plan à Québec a été annoncé
popour restructurer la raison de
lala santé. C'est au provinciale
lele faire et pas au fédéral de
nonous dire comment.
- - Martine, c'était très clair.
MoMonsieur Legault a voulu dire
quque Ford et la, on ne se la sa
papas cette fois-ci.
- - C'est le principal g grief e
MoMonsieur Legault et d'autres
prprovinces aussi c'est
l'l'ingérence dans les champs de
cocompétences. Il a passé
l'l'ensemble du mandat à se
dédéfendre à ce niveau-là. Quand
ilil a vu cette annonce là, il a
didire qu'il va tout de suite
memettre au point sur la table
popour savoir où je me place.
L'L'enjeu de l'assurance dentaie
çaça va être intéressant parce e
c'c'est imminent, l'annonce
dedevrait se faire lors du
prprochain budget fédéral. Ici,à
QuQuébec, ça fait parti des
didiscussions. Je me suis remémé
unune anecdote parce que lors de
l'l'élection de 2018, c'était ds
lele programme électoral de Quéc
sosolidaire, dans sa plate-forme
élélectorale de Québec solidair,
lala CAQ avait jonglé avec cette
ididée-là. On avait jongle avec
l'l'idée au début du mandat, on
avavait un peu mis ça sur la
glglace. C'est quand même un
prprogramme... l'idée fait son
chchemin. Peut-être que la CAQ a
enenvie d'avoir... de proposer e
gegenre de programme. Mais là, l
vovoudrait peut-être pas se faie
vovoler son punch et s'assurer
ququ'il pourra dépenser l'argent
cocomme il le veut et comme il
l'l'entend.
- - Christian Dufour, çaça vous
rarappelle Sereda bataille
ététernelle de champs de
cocompétences?
- - Vous lisez dans mes pensées.
DaDans envie, j'ai déjà travailé
coconseiller fédéral provincial.
MoMonsieur Trudeau, le NPD est
enencore plus centralisateur que
leles libéraux. C'est un milieu
memerveilleux adversaire que
d'd'avoir Ottawa. Je ne suis pas
rerevenu de cette alliance la
enentre le NPD et les libéraux.e
trtrouve que c'est honteux, mais
jeje ne sais pas si M. Singh pet
sese regarder dans le miroir. Ls
CaCanadiens ont décidé de régler
unun gouvernement minoritaire. x
momois après, on se retrouve avc
unune entente formelle entre les
dedeux parties. Ce n'est pas vri
quque ça s'est déjà passé de la
mmême façon. Il y a déjà eu des
enententes avant, mais là c'est
unune entente formelle après
l'l'élection. Il y avait pas
d'd'entente formelle. Je trouve
quque c'est vraiment pas respecé
lele mandat des électeurs ont
dodonné au gouvernement. C'est e
llà, M. Singh et Monsieur Trudeu
ququi font la morale à tout le
momonde tout le temps, ils aurot
hohonte car il ne respecte pas e
mamandat que les Canadiens leur
onont donné.  Avec des vrais
miministres au NPD, au moins, ça
seserait plus franc.
- - Monsieur Singh répond à ce e
vovous dîtes que le but est plus
imimportant, il dit : "je suis
prpragmatique, il y aura une
asassurance dentaire pour les 12
anans et moins, pour les 18 ans
enensuite, c'est plus important
quque tout le reste aussi.
StStéphanie?
- - Tout le monde pour la tarte
auaux pommes, c'est sûr que oui,
onon ne dira pas qu'un plan pour
cocouvrir les gens qui ont beson
dede son entasser mauvaise chos.
CeCe qui m'inquiète le plus, c't
jeje suis quand même d'accord ac
cece qu'a dit Christian que ça
chchange la donne avec ce qu'on
avavait t dit et émis à la boîtx
dedernières élections. Ce qui me
prpréoccupe, c'est d'un point de
vuvue financier, toutes les fois
ouoù les néo démocrates sont
alalliés aux libéraux, et
s's'entend, mais ils s s'entendt
popour toutes les mesures des dx
plplates-formes. Ça fait cher. s
lilibéraux ont déjà dépensé
énénormément d'argent en quatre
anans et demi. On a aussi plaidé
quque ça prenait plus de dépenss
ccôté militaires parce qu'on se
rerend compte qu'on a du cheminà
rarattraper puis là il y a une
guguerre.
AÀ la fin, ça fait beaucoup de
prpriorités. J'ai devant la
fafacture au bout de la ligne.
- - Et ceux qui ont des crainte,
cece qui avait des craintes de
MoMonsieur Trudeau seul, n'est s
trtrop, là, ils ont plus de
crcraintes.
- - Les Canadiens n'ont pas vot.
S'S'ils avaient voulu avoir le
prprogramme du NPD, ils auraient
vovoté pour Monsieur Singh. C'et
ssûr qu'il va y avoir des
didivisions, non seulement sur a
fafacture, mais aussi sur la fan
dodont va présenter les différes
prprojets.
- - Très bien, combien il nous
rereste de temps? On a un très
cocourt tour de table sur une
ququestion très simple. Je
cocommence avec vous, Martine,
rarapidement. Est-ce qu'on
dédéconfinement trop vite?
- - Il n'y a aucun appétit à
QuQuébec pour confiner davantag,
popour ajouter des mesures
sanitaires. On ne veut pas
paparler de ça.
- - On est allé rapidement, là,l
rereste le masque. Je pense qu'l
fafaut être prudent, ils n'y a s
dede raison d'aller devant et
atattendons voir ce que ça donn.
OnOn a vu ce que ça a donné qu'n
esessaie de prévoir un trop long
teterme. Ça fait encore plus ma.
- - Le bilan de M. Boileau
auaujourd'hui était quand même
rarassurant, puis heureusement.n
esest plus dans la guerre en
UkUkraine, on est dans un autre
paparadigme. Ça passerait très
didifficilement, des mesures
hohostiles. C'est l'apocalypse,
c'c'est la guerre en Ukraine.
- - Merci à vous trois, très
didiscipliné, très intéressant.
VoVous n'aurez pas de courri